okay so last time we enacted the Monty
Hall problem and that was a it comes
from this game show that had three
dollars in it and behind one of the
doors was a prize and then behind the
other two doors there was something
undesirable like a girl or something
else we didn't want okay so here's how
we're going to explain understand what's
going on and why it's be
counterintuitive okay when we start off
everyone agrees that there is a
probability of 1/3 1/3 for every door
that you pick that the surprise is
actually behind there ok because there
are 3 doors and it's an equal chance for
each one you don't know anything okay
now after you choose the door I think
remember you chose door to you then get
one of the other doors open for you say
it was door 3 right and I show you that
there's or Monty Hall shows you but
there is no prize behind there so this
is no longer an option and then you get
that choice of sticking with your
original door - or switching ok now most
people would then say at this point in
time there are no longer 3 options there
are two options ok so that means that
instead of there being a 1/3 1/3 1/3
chance there are now 2 choices so it
should be 1/2 and 1/2 50/50 but in fact
there aren't it's not a 50/50 chance the
reason why is that the reason there were
3 equal probabilities before is that you
do nothing about the situation all of
the options were completely independent
and equal to each other ok but once I
opened this door because I as the host
actually know what's going on I have
information I know where the prize is
that actually adds information into the
situation that changes these they're no
longer equal in fact they should
actually be the door that you stuck with
is 1/3 it remains a third but the other
door
is now 2/3 okay now there are two ways
to visualize this and try and understand
it the first way of thinking about it is
like this see how we originally chose
this door right third so this was your
choice okay
if you don't think that this way the
other two doors have a probability of
2/3 there's a 2/3 probability that the
price is behind the other doors that you
have chosen okay
but then I opened this door and show you
the prize isn't there so there is now a
zero chance that the prize is here okay
but there was 2/3 before on these two
doors so if there's two-thirds of these
doors combined but I opened this door at
Ricky there is no prize behind it so
this is a zero then if these two must
add up together now two-thirds of this
is zero then two-thirds must sort of
transfer from two doors all onto one
okay so that's one way of thinking about
that the probability of both these are
the doors that you didn't choose they've
kind of condensed and distilled and now
this the extending one door okay so
there's the first way to think about it
the second way is kind of a more a
step-by-step approach so what we want to
do is consider these two scenarios and
think about what happens for each one
okay
so let's consider what happens if you
decide before you even walk in before
you make a choice at all whatever
happens you're gonna stick with the door
you're not gonna let the young the game
host manipulate you or change a choice
you're just gonna stick with your
original choice in the matter what if
that's the case then the process of me
like oh pretty good door it doesn't
change anything
right so therefore these original
probabilities are still the same you
just have if you're going to stick with
your original choice you just have a
probability of 1/3 right so that's
unchanged now let's consider what
happens if you switch if you switch all
the time if you switch in a matter what
happens okay so if this is now the
scenario where considerable let's unveil
this a little bit and let's suppose we
knew like the game host $30 which prize
which door is behind
has the price behind them okay so we
know that I've got the UM suppose I know
the prize is here there's no prize there
and no prize there okay so let's
consider the options you chose door to
right and so there was a one-third
chance that you chose the prize and just
by luck
you did okay now when you what you have
that don't you've chosen it is a host
now have two choices for you I'm going
to open so I open this one right if I
open the door that means that there are
only two doors left there's the prize
door and a non-price door right so
therefore if you chose the prize door in
the first place there's a chance of a
third right that means that if you
switch you're gonna hit the no prize
door okay so if you switch you're always
going to switch then your chance of
losing you need a no prize tour is the
same as if you're chosen the first door
in the beginning right
so therefore what's the way win right
well the way to win if you're going to
switch is by picking the non prize door
in the first place
okay so now let's suppose you did it
pick the prize door you picked this one
here okay
so you said I want this door and because
I'm the host I know which doors have the
prize which door has the prize I can't
open this one so I must open this one
okay so I open the note prize door which
means if you switch you switch on to the
prize okay so therefore the probability
of winning by switching is the same as
choosing a non-price door to begin with
okay and the probability of doing that
is 2/3
right so therefore if you switch all the
time to decide you can switch then it is
twice as likely that you're going to win
it's not 50/50 they're not the same
chance it's vastly more likely they'll
win if you switch